prince george and princess charlotte
here
what was this moment like and what did
it mean to them we also saw charlotte
helping george at one point yeah it was
only announced really at the 11th hour
that we would have prince george and
princess charlotte given their ages just
seven and nine very very young to be
going to a funeral and particularly a
state funeral with the eyes of the world
on them for parents
william and kate who have been very keen
to keep them out of the public gaze and
so i think it was it was a clear message
i think it was a clear message
underlining all of this
this is the future this is the future of
the dynasty this is a projection of
what's to come you know george is now
second in line to the throne and i think
the significance of having charlotte was
and this is the spare we've always had
an air and a spare it dates back
centuries ago when you needed that you
know royals would die in childbirth you
needed that security um but actually
you look back and you see the queen was
supported by princess margaret her
sister charles was supported by the
princess royal princess sam
william was supported up until recently
by harry's that notion of the air and
the spare is something that we're now
seeing continued in charlotte and george
and it's rather lovely it was beautiful
and you could see their relationship how
important it was
[Music]